this is interesting all right remember
there's a zoo somewhere here in the
states where you could name a cockroach
after your ex or Valentine's Day raise a
little money well the animal foundation
has got a little spin on that you of
course could send ten dollars to them
and they'll send a cute wonderful little
e-card you know probably like a cute
puppy or cute kitty oh that's sweet but
for fifteen dollars the animal
foundation will put someone's name on a
litter box and then one of their cats is
gonna use that litter box do their
business oh my it doesn't end there
though the animal foundation will that
email the person a card with a picture
of the kitty doing its business
remember you're raising money for the
animal foundation here wait a second the
card for someone you love is ten dollars
the card for someone you don't love is
15. well yeah because you got it it's a
whole litter box situation thing don't
waste the opportunity